in 2003 nine billion human our
solitare were played computer solitaire
nine billion human hours it took only
seven million human hours to build the
entire Empire State Building and that's
equivalent seven million is equivalent
to only six point eight hours of people
playing solitaire around the world so
then the number of hours that are spent
playing games on computers or video
games is extremely large so one
sixteenth of our time in the United
States is spent playing computer in
video games what I want to do is I want
to make good use of that time see the
thing is while people are playing games
they're using the brains I want to
somehow make use of that time that
people are actually playing games and
using their brains for something that's
productive I want them to continue
playing the games but at the same time
have them also be doing something useful
for humanity and so what I've done is
I've developed a bunch of different
games which we call games with a purpose
that as people are playing these games
they're actually solving problems for us
you